this program is brought to you by Emory
University well it was a most exciting
event for me the birth of any baby large
or small is exciting because it's a new
little person into the world and have
three at one time was quite phenomenal
we used our new delivery room which was
designed to be larger so that we could
accommodate multiple births and we had
three special beds lined up and set up
with our three small teams we didn't
need huge teams to receive the babies
they were wonderfully large triplets at
36 weeks gestation they miss Salinas had
grown them so nicely that they were just
well nourished and perfect in every way
the babies are doing very well two of
the babies needed CPAP overnight
temporarily this big guy didn't need
much of anything and so they're now all
on room air and they're trying to learn
to eat mrs. Salinas will be discharged
to borrow but we have rooming in rooms
that we can make available for her so
that she can stay with her babies until
at least one of them goes home and that
will help her milk production and will
help these babies learn to nurse
successfully of course they're going to
have to learn how to take a bottle as
well as breastfeed because that's just
you can just do so much but having a
combination of with a lot of breast milk
involved will be very helpful for their
long-term development the babies arrived
with the in-house babysitters having
three teenaged sisters and they were
here at soon after the delivery and were
in the NICU with their brothers and it's
really very
dear to see this sweet family with three
older girls and now three baby boys
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University